at this altitude I can run flat-out for
my hands this episode is brought to you
by four Sigma deck if you're a longtime
listener of the show or brand new to the
podcast my favorite Finnish
entrepreneurs who founded this company
of course I don't know that many Finnish
entrepreneurs but they may be my
favorites have something new that I've
been loving and some of you are familiar
with for sig Matic I've used their
products for years now they were
introduced to me by an acrobat of all
folks and they tend to mix different
types of medicinal mushrooms into their
products I have recently started using
their matcha which is a green tea which
is designed as a coffee alternative and
if you're trying to cut back on caffeine
as I am these days the matcha is a great
option and one that I originally learned
to love in Japan has a very smooth
texture to it they're macho blend in
particular includes the amino acid
l-theanine which helps to provide a
let's call it balanced boost of energy
without the jitters it also includes the
adaptogen astrologists from pronouncing
that correctly which may help with
overall stress tolerance and for those
of you who are wondering know the
products don't taste like mushrooms if
they say mushroom coffee for instance
another product that I use doesn't taste
like mushrooms it tastes like coffee but
you get the nutritional benefits of some
of these special ingredients so the
products don't taste like mushrooms and
are enjoyable I offer them to my
houseguests and use them myself and I
don't particularly want to drink
anything that tastes like mushrooms so
moving on the folks at forcing Matic
have designed a few special deals for
you guys my listeners which include many
of my favorite products of theirs so
check it out visit for sig Matic fo you
are SI g ma TI c comp or slash tim-tim
that's t IMT IM no space to see these
special deals which are not offered any
where else remember to use the code Tim
Tim I don't know why they just tempt him
but there we go remember to use the code
Tim Tim a check out to receive your
special discount again that's for sig
Matic dot-com forward slash Tim Tim and
enter the promo code Tim Tim check it
out this episode is brought to you by
wordpress.com
I love WordPress I have used it for so
many years it's my go-to platform for
blogging and creating websites I use
wordpress.com for everything every day
my site Tim not blog is built on it the
websites for my books including tools of
titans tribe of mentors it's all on
wordpress.com and the founder matt
mullenweg
when my close friends has appeared on
this show many times
just search Matt Mullenweg tequila
Ferriss for quite an exciting time
whether you're looking to create a
personal blog a business site or both
you can make a really big impact right
out of the box when you build on
wordpress.com and you'll be in good
company it's used by the New Yorker
jay-z Beyonce 5:38 TechCrunch Ted CNN
and time just to name a handful and one
of my friends at Google shall remain
nameless has told me that wordpress.com
offers the quote best out-of-the-box
SEO imaginable end quote and it's one of
the many reasons that nearly 30% of the
Internet is run on WordPress you do not
need experience or to hire someone
that's perhaps the best part
wordpress.com guides you through the
entire experience they have hundreds of
designs and templates that you can use
and it's easy to get started there's no
need to worry about security upgrades
hosting any of that therefore 24/7
support and they're very very responsive
if you have questions they get right
back to you and this allows you to
create the highest quality with the
least amount of headache and friction so
if you're building a website period when
my friends come to me and ask what I use
what I recommend they use the answer is
wordpress.com so check it out if you
want to get started today learn more
with a 15% discount off any new plan go
to wordpress.com forward slash Tim to
create your website and
the plan is right for you so learn more
take a look wordpress.com forward slash
Tim for 15% off a brand new website
check it out
hello my pretty daddy Mogwai this is Tim
Ferriss and welcome to another episode
of the Tim Ferriss show where it is my
job to deconstruct world-class
performers to tease out the habits
routines life lessons favorite books and
so on that you can use and this episode
we have a true polymath Joseph
gordon-levitt on Twitter and Instagram
at hit record Jo like it record on a
video camera hit record Joe and his site
is hit record org Joe is an actor whose
career spans three decades and ranges
from television ie third Rock from the
Sun or I should say eg to art house
mysterious skin brick to multiplex like
Inception 500 days of summer Snowden he
made his feature screen writing and
direct oral debut with Don John which
had an Independent Spirit Award
nomination for Best first screenplay he
also founded and directs hit record an
online community of artists around
600,000 now emphasizing collaboration
over self-promotion hit record has
evolved into a community sourced
production company that publishes books
puts out records produces videos for
brands from LG to the ACLU and has won
an Emmy for its variety show hit record
on TV so without further ado please
enjoy this wide-ranging conversation
with Joseph gordon-levitt Joe welcome to
the show thanks man thanks for having me
of course it it's been a while since we
last caught up and I have so many
questions and now I get to ask them in a
public forum so thank you for taking the
time
oh yeah yeah well I'm I'm really excited
to to be on your show
it's um I'm I'm a listener longtime
listener first-time caller and I'm
flattered to be in the company of the
people that you talk to on this show man
it's it's really cool thank you of
course it's it's completely my pleasure
and I thought we might start of course
where where I start is not going to be
where we go since the the format of my
shows is generally closest to the movie
as I mentioned before we get started
buns I reached out to as I often like to
do with guests a mutual friend
to ask a question that I very frequently
ask which is and I'll tell you the text
that I sent and you'll be able to guess
who this is
okay I'm partially because I'm gonna say
the name exclamation point
yeah yeah the in ages man hope you're
great you know finally interviewing Joe
and we've had a few chats and one dinner
in the last year might you be able to
suggest any particular topics questions
or stories that could be fun or
interesting to explore does his answer
involve balls it doesn't but now we have
to talk about balls balls goes on the
list for sure how could it not and he
gave me a number of different thoughts
and recommendations and then he added
like 20 minutes later and he can breathe
fire if you tickle his feet have fun so
I wanted to I wanted to fact-check that
first because knowing Evan I'm suspect
so true or false can you breathe fire if
I tickle your feet that depends on your
state of mind that's that's Evan
Goldberg by the way for those who could
you explain for people who are like who
the hell is Evan who is Evan and how did
you first meet yeah Evan Goldberg is
known for being writing partners with
Seth Rogen and Seth and Evan are like
the the comedy pair and they started by
writing super bad together and they
wrote it about themselves in fact the
character names of super bad if you go
back and watch it again are Seth and
Evan and I think I think Michael Cera is
playing Evan right and and Jonah Hill is
playing Seth if I'm not mistaken which
is wildly inaccurate to who they are but
but funny anyway and yeah they're
they're just two really hilarious guys
we did two movies together the first one
was 5050
and then the second one was called the
night before and they're really really
smart dudes which is funny because they
make they make humor that
probably doesn't get regarded as smart
but as with many things in in movies I
find oftentimes the stuff that is
considered lowbrow or sort of mainstream
or pop is often the most intelligently
constructed which applies to them
sometimes yeah they're very very very
smart guys and just to paint a picture
for folks
Evon always were shorts he does all his
meetings standing up just about which
can cause some anxiety if you don't know
why he's standing and don't realize
that's what he always says or he'll be
in like a deep squat like an Olympic
weightlifter which is he always says
sitting is the new smoking right and
protip for anyone who might bump into
these these folks if you sit down with
them and they're brainstorming I would
advise you not to smoke with them unless
you consider yourself a really good spot
really really strong smoker I've been
working with them in phases in my life
where I was smoking a lot in phases in
my life where I was not smoking a lot
and the first time I met them well I
wasn't the first time we met but with
the first time we really hung out they
were asking me to do their movie 5050
and I flew up to Vancouver where they
were on time was short for reasons that
don't really matter for the story um and
they had to cast this role really
quickly as happens all the time in show
business and so I've read the script and
that night flew up to Vancouver to sit
down with Seth and Evan and John Levine
who was directing the movie and we had a
good talk about the movie and talked
about the things that one normally talks
about and then we sort of got to a point
where that part of the meeting you know
came to a natural conclusion
at which point Seth pulled out a joint
and we went up to the roof and smoked
and then had kind of what felt like the
real meeting you know was not it's like
meeting with Chinese bureaucrats except
they're not Chinese and you're using a
different substance they'll bring out
something called by Joe which is this
horrific alee strong and unpleasant
alcohol and that's that's when the real
meeting starts Wow
Yesi to me smoking weed and strong
alcohol could not be two experiences
that are more different from each other
that's not everyone's experience and
that I mean look everyone has their you
know their own I think reaction to
different substances and I'm not one of
those weed smokers that encourages
people to smoke weed because I do think
it's different for everyone but for me
at least at certain times in my life
it's it's not brain killing it's quite
the opposite my brain would kind of leap
places that it it might not otherwise
and those guys well I should I should
mention a few things for folks so number
one if you're going to be see like
you're going into the Dragons Den of
high potency plant matter so you really
have your wits about you second for
those people we won't spend too much
time on this but were interested in what
Master Sommeliers of pot ie Evan and
Seth would recommend like the the pot
that they use for creative work the pot
that they use for functions
a B C D and E we do talk about it in the
podcast that I did with the two of those
guys so yeah you can check it out the
reason I brought him up aside from the
bullets and then the balls that I've put
on to my list now that we blow that it's
just because you know they get paid lots
of money to make jokes about balls ah
yeah he uh he surmounted my expectation
he exceeded my expectations by making
the fire-breathing joke that was much
more tasteful than a joke balls
the first thing he said wasn't a joke at
all and you alluded to it just a moment
ago then I wanted to ask you that first
thing he said and so I've known Evan for
a while we've had plenty of exchanges so
the very first thing he says is he's
awesome he saved our movie 5050 and I'm
gonna edit what he said slightly
afterwards but he said such and such a
person was cast and he had to drop out
and Joe replaced him in 24 hours which
is all the time we had before they shut
us down and I forever loved him for it
so why did you choose to do that movie
hmm yeah I mean I should say I'm the
person who had to drop out it was you
know a family emergency so there was no
bad blood between anybody but yeah why
do I choose I mean it's it's a it's a
larger question that I think applies
here the same as really any movie and
why choose any given movie I mean the
first thing to say is I'm incredibly
lucky to get to choose what role I do or
don't take and it wasn't always that way
for many many years I started acting
when I was six and for like a long long
time up until actually pretty much just
a few years ago well it's more than a
few now isn't it getting old play I
would just audition and take the part
that if I got a part then that was great
news and I would do the part that I got
I would win on lots of auditions and and
so I I come from the the mentality of
it's amazing to get a role however in
recent years when I've been fortunate
enough to be able to kind of pick what I
do and don't do it's sort of the only
power you have as an actor in a way is
the power to say no because once once
you say yes movies really aren't the
actors medium and that's really cool and
can also be frustrating
the context if you're working with a
director and other filmmakers who you're
on the same page with it can be
incredible to have them there you know
sort of bringing forth and and kind of
refining and presenting the work that
you do but if you're not on the same
page with somebody it can be really
frustrating because you can try all you
want to make the performance what you
think it should be but you know
ultimately it's gonna be up to the
director because what I think often gets
overlooked or under emphasized is just
how big a role all the other factors are
when you you think you're watching an
actor give the performance and you are
watching that actor but you're also
watching the work of the editor and you
know the camera crew you're listening to
the work of the musicians and oh you
know productions and all these other
factors that all contribute to the
feeling that you get when you watch a
performance and and so what makes me say
yes is when I feel good and on the same
page with mostly the director because
it's should be the directors job to kind
of be steering the whole entire ship
with all of those elements in the same
direction it's not always just the
director sometimes like in the case of
5050 with Seth and Evan there's John
Levine who is very much the director but
also Seth and Evan who are producing our
you know big parts of the collaborative
process and they're they're very
collaborative in general and that was
one of the things I liked about their
situation that they create is they
really let the actors in and it's a very
collaborative thing and you can feel
like you trust them they're not they're
not gonna tell you they want one thing
and be doing something else or try to
trick you into anything and you know
that'll there's there's a phrase
sometimes it gets said people will say
to a director oh you really got a great
performance out of
that actor and I was feel like that's
not really how I would put it you know
and some directors do sort of try to
take the proactive role and be like it's
up to me to get this performance out of
you and so I'm gonna use my manipulation
or whatever it takes to like force you
into feeling what I need you to feel
right now which to me feels adversarial
and in my experience doesn't usually
work as well as let's all be on the same
team and I'm gonna you know where the
director is supporting the actor to help
the actor do what they need to do and
then presenting all in making sure all
the other elements are on the same page
so that it all comes together in a
cohesive way and the audience can feel
it it's you mentioned directing and as
someone who's never been involved with
film although I've been involved with
some unscripted television which is
totally different animal less different
than you might suppose that's true a lot
of unscripted television is exactly
scripted let's be clear and just for
people at home who are who might watch
some reality TV if you ever see a lot of
people standing in a kitchen and there's
someone mixing a random thing in a bowl
like they're not actually mixing
anything and why are they all standing
in the kitchen because there's natural
light like no one in real life does that
so that was planned but the the I think
the difference between unscripted in
script it is if you call the writers
producers you don't have to pay them as
much so I read somewhere that you've
talked about the ability to balance a
thorough plan with spontaneity being the
crux or at the crux of being a good
director and I don't want to misquote
you but that's I think that's true so
I'd love to hear since you have worn
many hats you are not just an actor Eve
than many others
could you tell us maybe a story or give
an example of directors you've worked
well with and things they've done to
help you or to help the entire movie
move well and just if there are any
particular stories and just what comes
to mind for me as someone who really
doesn't know much about this at all
remember someone telling me at one point
this instead of saying action Clint
Eastwood would say or maybe still says
whenever you're ready even not to say
that makes a big difference but there
there are varied and then Robert
Rodriguez living now in Austin Texas as
I do I've gotten to know and he'll play
music in between takes he'll actually
hire artists to help people learn how to
paint while they're on set as a way of I
didn't painting on Rodriguez's set yeah
that's right yeah that's right that's
right
and I'd be curious to know what
directors you've worked with have have
done from from that perspective to to
help things that you've you've found
memorable and then also what you've done
when when directing other people and and
how you but how you've forged your own
style as director sure let's see well
the first feature film I was ever in was
a movie called a river runs through it
which was directed by Robert Redford
[Music]
who's a great actor turned director and
I was 10 and I remember this is one of
my favorite stories uh it we were doing
a scene where I had to walk up to my dad
at his desk and sort of show him
something I had written and and we did a
few takes and I wasn't hitting my mark a
mark is a little piece of tape that they
put down on the floor so that when you
walk into a room you hit that mark
and that mark is important for you to
hit because they've set up the camera
they've set up all the lights to all
look good for the actor to stand in that
exact position and if the actor is
standing in a different position well
it'll look different and by the way the
cinematographer for a river runs through
it won an Oscar for this movie and mmm
and he the the DP director of
photography which is the same as
cinematographer he walked up to me after
the second time or whatever that I
missed my mark and and very nicely asked
me to you know make sure that I stood on
the mark stood where that green piece of
tape was on the floor and I was nervous
I was ten and I'd been on plenty of sets
before I'd been working I think I said
since I was six but but no matter who
you are how long you've been doing it it
doesn't feel good to mess up twice and
like have to you know get a note like
that
and you're not the only person on the
set right now I would imagine this is
you have you have more than how many
people are around you as you're filming
something like this Oh a hundred I'd say
yeah around a hundred and that's like a
standard film crew ish and and so I you
know really was staring at that green
piece of tape on the floor and knew that
when we did the next tape I was
definitely going to walk in and stand
right exactly
on that green piece of tape and that's
what I was focused on and right before
they rolled camera Redford came up to me
and just quietly said in my ear I never
hit my marks that's all he said he
walked away and that would that was so
important because on the one hand yes
it's you know here's this oscar-winning
cinematographer who set up the shot and
if the actor is not on the mark the shot
won't look the way that he wants it to
look but I think I think mr. Redford had
a you know a lot of wisdom there to know
that no matter how good the shot looks
if your actor is focused on a green
piece of tape on the floor that's not
gonna really be worth watching that's a
great story that is a great story and I
suppose that's that's also part of the
gift that someone like Redford brings to
the table is that he has so much
experience in the shoes of actor yeah
and he was the first actor director that
I had ever worked for and I really loved
that and that's a perfect example of why
because of just what you're getting at
that he could say with authority I never
hit my marks which I'm sure he's
exaggerating I'm sure he does it is
marks but he just he needed to you know
correct my head there for a sec any
other any other directors come to mind
who have have lent memorable experiences
to your to your memory banks I mean yeah
sure there's tons I'm trying to think of
a really good example I mean you know
this might sound like I'm name-dropping
but watching Steven Spielberg set up a
shot is pretty special I remember asking
him about shot listing shot listing is
sort of a standard thing that a director
does it's just you write down kind of
all the different shots that you want to
get for a scene because in any given
scene you might have you know you might
want to capture it from three angles
four angles five angles depending on how
you like to do it so I asked him and
this is actually in 2011 when I was
shooting for him in a movie called
Lincoln which was just the year before I
got to direct movie so I was really
thinking about it
I've always ever since I was young kind
of follow directors and tried to soak up
what I can put at that time I was really
really thinking about directing soon and
I asked him if
shot listed and he showed me in his
script a couple of like tiny little
lines that were just no one would have I
mean a shot list when I shot my movie a
shot list is like was a long document
with lots of description about all the
different shots that we did for every
scene he had like a couple of pencil
marks in in his script because he just I
figured that he would be a meticulous
shot Lister as well because his shots
are so well composed and he doesn't
really at least he didn't on Lincoln and
why was that yeah why is that
why did by the difference I think
because he's just got such facility that
he would prefer and this gets back to
the original point of spontaneity versus
planning he would prefer to watch what
the actors do and figure out how he
wanted to shoot it based on that
rather than have the actors have to fit
into a pre-planned sort of shot list and
that's what he would do and when we
would we would show up to rehearsal he
wouldn't be thinking about camera yet
some directors do he wouldn't
do you think he had just out of
curiosity if you had to speculate do you
think he had shot lists earlier in his
career in the sense that was he was he
someone who learned the rules and
followed the rules for a period of time
until he was so expert following the
rules that he realized he could abandon
some of them or do you think he's
operating that way from the beginning
and I raised it in part because I
recently watched a documentary and I
think it's simply titled Spielberg about
his life and it's a fantastic HBO
documentary I enjoyed it at least a
painted a very human picture of him
including his frailties and weaknesses
and failures and how he's contended with
them but do you think that he's always
operated that way or that he
later only having become this virtuoso
with confidence then abandoned the shot
list I would guess the former I I can't
confirm that and I never quite asked him
that but I would guess that when he was
shooting jaws or when he was shooting
Raiders the Lost Ark that he had some
shot lists that would be my guess
although he was famous a while for going
wildly over budget so who knows but you
know the story about the shark fin
that's sort of a that's an old why don't
you own story why don't you tell the
story because it's so good okay for
those those of you out there who like my
wife don't know the lore of movies if
you've ever seen jaws which is one of
the most powerful movies ever it's about
a shark and you never see the shark you
but you see its fin sticking out of the
water and the story goes I never asked
him about this because I'm sure he's
sick of talking about it but the story
goes that they had planned to see the
shark a lot in the movie and they had
built this big animatronic shark and
they had you know nicknamed mr. moose I
didn't know that and it didn't work they
got on set and like you know like
anything technical it [ __ ] up and so
his solution was okay well we can't see
the shark let's just can we can we make
it work so that we can see its fin
sticking out of the water and if you see
the movie it's so effective the shark is
so much scarier because you never see it
you just see this fin and it's so
ominous and they didn't know that that
was gonna happen so the bat speaks to
the point you brought up again
spontaneity versus pre-planning that's
that's exactly being a film director
you're you're on a set days of
production are so expensive you know and
and directing a movie is like a
two-year process wherein you're actually
shooting for like two months of it but
you're spending I don't know what the
actual number is but some huge
percentage of your budget is going into
this very small sliver of time and so
you're always on the clock and you've
planned everything but then something
else will happen either something will
[ __ ] up or some new great idea will
emerge all of a sudden and it's up to
you to decide at that moment on the
clock should I stick to the plan or
should I go with this new thing that
just came up and the ones who can kind
of make that decision well in my
experience are the best directors so
I've I have a number of follow questions
but I'll also just mention something
that I stuck in my mind from a director
even though I've never been directed per
se as you have I mentioned Robert
Rodriguez and he was in it's been in the
last two of my books in fact both tools
of Titan's and Trevor men tourism was on
this podcast that's when I first met him
in person it was to have him on this
podcast and he said to me at one point
something along the lines of the
following and you've met Robert so you
can imagine him saying this with this
gigantic smile on his face he always
seems to have a big gigantic smile on
his face
he has a lot of fun he's a big dude so
it's an especially big smile
he's like the Tony Robbins of filmmaking
that's always optimistic
I shouldn't say always but in my
experience with them he's very upbeat
dude and he said you know have these
young filmmakers come to me all the time
and they say yeah you know I've ran this
project I was working on this thing but
the lighting didn't work and then the
you know the grip [ __ ] this thing up
and then this and this and this
he said the point I always make his like
that's your job is that nothing is going
to work like they don't understand that
the job description of filmmaker is like
nothing is going to work it's true yeah
if everything worked a director would
just be able to show up and say action
kinda like right because you should like
if everything was done properly then the
actors will have rehearsed and kind of
know what they're gonna do and ever you
know everything should be shot listed
and prepared and I mean of course
everyone has their own methods but the
truth is the director does do a lot more
than action and cut and I think it comes
back to the same thing that we're
talking about is like because on the day
things always arise that you don't
expect and you're really there has to be
one person who's making those decisions
because it would take too long if if
those decisions were made by committee
right yeah too expensive you can't
afford the delays and on the jaws point
in addition to the fin for those people
who have seen or wants to see it there
there are these open water scenes which
by the way much much more complex than
Spielberg expected to film and so the
even the fin what was difficult to use
and they didn't want to overuse it so
they came up with on the spot the idea
of using these barrels to track the
shark and for those of you who want to
check it out you can revisit that but it
was absolutely an example of the
improvising that that you mentioned the
ability to improvise how did you learn
to direct now putting putting aside if
possible the fact that you had been
directed so much so you've been
absorbing through osmosis perhaps quite
a bit
given your career but when you knew that
on the horizon you're going to be
directing your own film and how did you
go about learning more about directing
the craft
maybe the technical side whatever it is
that you felt you need to know what was
your approach to learning how to do that
well yeah first of all I just had the
advantage of being on a set a lot and
watching a lot of directors on a set so
that part kind of came naturally but
there's a lot more to directing than the
time on the set I think the other one
other thing that I
came to focus on though was editing em
cuz as an actor you never get to be in
the editing room you're not really aware
of that whole process and it's a huge
huge part of what makes a movie and I
love editing I remember when I was
growing up I always wanted to edit but
you you couldn't yet that wasn't
available to consumers yet sounds hard
to believe now because you can you know
edit video on your phone nowadays but
when I was you know first starting to
you know make fun little videos with my
buddies when I was 10 or whatever and we
were using our family video camera which
you know weighed more than 50 iPhones
all duct-taped together
editing was sort of a Holy Grail because
we would try something and I'd be like
oh wait I wish we could do it again but
you kind of can't do it again unless you
can edit and you kind of could if you
set it up it was real pain in the ass if
you tried to like dub what you had shot
on the video camera onto an old VHS VCR
and you know hit the pause button it's
just the right moment and then find the
next thing and dub again and hopefully
the cut was sort of smooth but it never
was anyway when when editing finally
became something you could just do on a
computer at home I was thrilled and for
my 21st birthday I got myself a new
computer and my first copy of Final Cut
Pro and this is like 2002 and I mean I
ended up dropping out of college because
I was just so fascinated with sitting
there and editing and okay so just just
sorry no no no we're not skipping ahead
we're jumping all over to the right
places so just for people who don't have
this context maybe we should revisit
this see you went from
show business so to speak back to school
and then the so this was one of the
catalyzing events then for leaving
school was getting his final cut pro it
was a hundred percent catalyzing event
because I would be sitting there at
night and I was supposed to be writing a
paper for college and all I wanted to do
was edit and I was like I think I have
to drop out of school alright you know
there's there's no set script for this
conversation so let's let's talk about
that for a second we can come back to
directing because I want to certainly
talk more about your own experience with
your film yeah but why did you of all
things why go back to school why did you
decide place us in time like where were
you what were you doing when you decided
to go back to school and why went
because a lot of folks are thinking of
you your name impressive career why do
that what was uh what was the scene if
you can set us up with a description of
where you were in life and how you made
that decision well I mean I've been
acting since I was six years old and was
lucky enough to do it pretty
consistently throughout my childhood and
adolescence is it true just as a quick
side note because I've drinking green
tea since we started so now I have more
personality is it true that you used to
blow out your birthday candles wishing
for gigs or something like that is am I
making that up am i hallucinating is
that no that's that's something in a
magazine that's true there's a lot in
the magazines they may not be true okay
cool so I didn't mean to interrupt
though so yes you've been you'd had this
long career already like starting at age
six and well I had always wanted to go
to college you know my my dad actually
dropped out of college but my mom really
spoke very highly of University and at
the end and even got her master's and
I was just always really looking forward
to that I'd always liked school I was
always sort of studious I liked learning
and always frankly found elementary
school junior high high school a little
lacking in in what I was really wanting
and was hoping that once I got to
college then I would like be in these
classes that were just blowing my mind
all the time and so yeah and and I think
also besides besides the academics I
wanted to not know my future I always
had write and I never and that makes
perfect sense
I you know I was around all my friends
who were you know some of them were
going to college some of them weren't
but they all were you know finishing
high school and starting off on life and
like figuring out what they wanted to do
it what they wanted to be and and I felt
like wait I shouldn't I shouldn't just
let my six-year-old self make the
decision for me of what I'm gonna be for
my whole life I should I should be also
making that decision not just six year
old me and and so I thought it'd be it'd
be right to quit acting for a while and
just go to school and that's what I did
I and I think is one of the one of the
better decisions I've ever made both to
quit for a while and also to move away
from home
you know not everybody can afford to
move away from home but luckily I I was
able to and living in a new city while
on the one hand really challenging is a
huge growth spurt just for who you are
and what you think and what you know and
I loved moving away where where were you
moving from and where did you move to I
grew up in the San Fernando Valley
Sherman Oaks which is a suburb in LA
although
la is sort of a suburb because it
doesn't have a center like a
conventional city but but this is really
the suburbs and and I moved to New York
City like Manhattan Columbia University
is where I went and I mean I still miss
New York I don't live there anymore but
New York City's just incredible walking
around you know in in LA
you don't walk so much you mostly drive
places and my favorite things still my
favorite thing to do in New York is not
any particular restaurant or bar or site
or anything it's just walk out your door
wherever you are and walk and see what
you see and see who you see and I I get
so much inspiration from doing that
whenever I go to that city it is an
amazing city that you ultimately as you
mentioned not too long ago found final
cut and that was the end of school what
did you choose to major in and why and
besides moving away from home why did
you find it to be a valuable experience
well I was about halfway through a
bachelor's when I decided to drop out so
choosing a major was looming but I never
actually had to do it but I was it would
have been a French major because by that
time I was taking my classes in French
because I I frankly and this isn't any
sort of slight Columbia University where
I went I just found myself
I think underwhelmed in the academic
setting I there were some classes that
really interested me but one thing I
really that really bothered me was you
were supposed to read so much that there
was no way you could read it thoroughly
right and I felt like I felt like that's
what I had been trying to get away from
high school where you having to like
prove to someone that you read something
and it's kind of condescending and not
not very enriching and I thought College
was gonna be something more than that
but and maybe it would have been if I
were using it right or maybe it would
have been if I had stuck around and you
know declared a major but but what I
really did like was studying in French
because then no matter what I was
learning just sitting in the class and
listening to the teacher speak French or
trying to read something in French kind
of no matter what the subject matter no
matter what the paper was supposed to be
on or what the test was or anything just
the fact that it was in another language
meant I was learning and I had always
wanted to speak another language
I felt I felt sort of inferior for not
speaking more than one language and and
I got to the point where I mean I
wouldn't say that I'm like a fluent
French speaker like someone who lives
there but you know I can have a
conversation with someone in French I
can read the newspaper slowly and and it
really taught me a lot about even about
English just about in about language to
definitely kind of have more than one in
my head why did you choose French just
cuz I think mostly because I liked
French movies an aesthetic thing my mom
studied French so I'd always kind of had
that in the air a sort of a frank
Ophelia and she lived in France for a
number of years and and you know spoke
about it really romantically and that's
one of my favorite moments in life is
like walking through Paris with my mom
and her being like this is where I
worked when I was younger than you are
now
I loved it here there there was a real
completion there too getting to do that
with her nowadays I you know I there's
probably other languages that would be
much more practical to learn but and not
just nowadays back then too but but yeah
aesthetically I just always found it
really appealing and I like to I think
with language not to not
to interject or add too much of my my
own thoughts here but languages clear
thoughts that languages can be very
challenging and I deeply feel that if
you as a native speaker say if English
we want to learn a language that you
should unless you need to absolutely get
a job that requires another language for
instance if you are a ethnic Indian
living in Dubai and you need to speak
English to work in the hospitality
industries in some capacity focus on
English otherwise I would suggest you
follow your interest in this case yours
was spurred by exposure of French films
because it's going to be they're going
to be challenging times and they're
going to be difficulties along the road
and you want to have the enthusiasm and
the passion that you feel for not just
the language but the culture to help you
get over those hurdles and I remember
very clearly when I was just starting as
an East Asian Studies major in college
to take Chinese I'd been taking Japanese
and I just started Chinese and there
were 60 kids in the class within two
weeks there were 12 kids in the class
because the pronunciation and so on is
so alien and so strenuous so stressful I
should say more accurately that it weeds
out a lot of people who are say just
there to develop a toolkit for a
perspective career that may or may not
even materialize later it's the people
who are obsessed with something really
odd like the II Ching or obsessed with
calligraphy or some weird at not they're
amazing Chinese movies oh and they're
amazing Chinese movies this is very very
true but but I don't take us down too
far around at all on the Chinese and so
on I want to come back to the question
of directing on the topic of directing
your own movies you you've directed
quite a number you mentioned when you
were working with Spielberg I suppose it
was maybe yearly
a year and a half later you're going to
be directing your own film which film
was that that move is called Don John so
Don John you as I understand it
wrote directed and starred in dodges how
did that what's the creation story why
did you choose to make this movie to
write direct and star in it and maybe
you could give and just a synopsis of
the not necessarily a synopsis but a
sentence or two or three or four or five
however many like on the the subject
matter yeah
well Don Jon's a sort of a take on the
old Don Juan story who's a you know a
mythical womanizer and it's about a guy
who's addicted to pornography and who I
think more than just being addicted to
pornography sort of objectifies
everything in his life not only women
but his friends his family his own body
his car his God he treats everything as
sort of an object much the same way as
he treats the women that he jerks off to
when he's watching porn and and has to
sort of have a self realization about
that and it's sort of a coming-of-age
story a coming-of-age story and why why
did I want to tell that story well it's
it's in many its in certain ways a story
about media which is something that I've
focused on my whole life and like I was
saying a story about how people
objectify other people and I guess
without without trying to sound like I'm
complaining I have felt kind of
objectified myself throughout my life
because of being in the media sure and
and and besides that sort of feeling
uncomfortable for me and there were
times in my life when I felt really
uncomfortable I had I mean I I had real
anxiety about it when I was younger and
I've I've gotten more comfortable with
it now but besides that I also think
that it's not really good for the
objectify or either - for people out
there who watch these faces on screens
and and see them as these I don't know
almost deified special entities that are
you know more important or more
attractive or you know more worthy of
celebration than the watcher I think
that's a really prominent idea in our
culture and one that deserves to be
attacked and made fun of and and so
that's when that's what the movie is
sort of about what what was hardest
about making that movie or getting it
distributed could be anything what were
what were some of the hardest aspects of
that if any come to mind yeah well
writings really hard it's super fun I
love writing but it's hard I think
partially because it's it's more of a
loner sport at least that one was for me
I wrote it myself and and I had a great
time doing it but I think probably if
you ask what's the hardest part it's
those moments where you know I'll be
sitting there having spent who knows how
many hours on this over the last X years
trying to make this script something
that I think is good and hearing a voice
in my head saying this is all been a
waste of time you should probably just
stop now
that kind of thing that's kind of the
story of my life right there
and because minoo one you can rarely
turn to to to fight that voice you have
to just in those moments just kind of
have to ignore it and you know or if the
voice is really getting the better you I
found I would just have to be like okay
I'm gonna have to stop for now I'll come
back to this later
were there any books or resources or
screenplays that you found particularly
helpful or motivating in the process of
of writing this I never read a book
about screenwriting I know they're out
there
I've glanced at some I skimmed through
one recently called save the cat which
was I thought smart in in a lot of ways
but also with all due respect to the
smart guy who wrote it sort of cynical
and off-putting in times and yeah I
don't know I I wouldn't I wouldn't I
don't want to say that I don't recommend
people read those books cuz there are
probably some really good good thoughts
in in those screenwriting books that
sort of talk about conventional
structure and the three acts and things
like that I sort of I guess got to take
in a way a short cut you know in a way a
long cut because I've just been around
it and I've read so many scripts over
the years I mean my mom was reading me
scripts before I could read and it's a
good good advantage so I have had a
certain osmosis I guess and look I
probably learned as much from the bad
scripts is from the good scripts and I
certainly read way more bad scripts than
just grips and and I also have you know
for me writing is a lot like acting
when you're when you're acting you spend
a lot of time with your scripts and so I
can you know when I'm writing a scene
I'm treating it much like I do when I'm
preparing to act in that scene and and
then I can read it and be like no that
doesn't feel good and I've had you know
so many experiences as an actor where
you're sitting there with a scene and
being like I just wished that this line
was phrased a little differently and
when you're the writer you can just
rewrite it which is nice yeah and
depending on the director you're working
with sometimes you can come in and say
you know hey can I say this a little bit
differently and that goes back to we
were saying about a director before
that's that's exactly one of those
moments where a director has to go huh
we've been sitting with that line that
way for all this time and now I have to
tell the actor yes or no yes you can
change it or no don't and there's you
know ways to approach that you can you
can always say let's try it both ways or
sometimes I found usually the actors
were right and the dialogue that I wrote
was much improved by the actors in Don
John Scarlett Johansson and Julianne
Moore and and other ones too who who
said lines that were ultimately you know
sometimes subtly different sometimes
quite a bit different than what I wrote
and I think really benefited so Joe you
mentioned being objectified having
experienced being objectified and this
this leads me to want to ask a question
about Fame in general because I have
many listeners many readers who say or
on Instagram or on fill-in-the-blank
social network snapchat whatever it
might be and they're very explicit goal
is to be as famous as possible to us as
many followers among other things there
are different indicators that
they would use to determine whether they
are famous enough or not but that is a
real explicit goal for a lot of folks
could you maybe share what you would say
to someone who is currently holding in
mind being famous as a goal yeah this is
something I think about a lot because I
guess I've experienced it to some degree
and being famous yeah I would say so
well from what I've seen and experienced
fame doesn't necessarily make you happy
and I think the assumption on the part
of the people you're describing is that
if they get a certain amount famous then
they'll be happy right because that's
really what we all want is to be happy
depending on how you define the word
happiness but I think that sort of is
the definition of happiness in a way is
what what we want to be and the people
that I know that have whatever amount of
fame some of them are happy some of them
are not happy and the fame isn't what
makes them happy you know what makes
somebody happy I think is you know do
you have your health do you have good
people around you do you get to do
things that you like doing and and
that's where it gets complicated because
sometimes having a certain amount of
fame does allow you to do the things
that you want to do so it's not a simple
answer and in there are trade-offs also
right it's not like you just get the
upside when you have a lot of public
exposure I mean I know even in my tiny
fake famous 14 minutes into my 15
minutes of fame capacity I've had to
sell houses before because
like a crazy person has gotten ahold of
the address and shown up huh
certainly without any announcement and
there's been a sort of perceived level
of threat associated with that and and
that isn't 1/100 of what you've
experienced so there are sort of
commensurate with your degree of Fame
very real trade-offs yeah for sure there
there are real life trade-offs like that
although I would say the the thing
that's that's much more impactful isn't
real life invasion of privacy in your
physical space it's more an invasion
into your mental to your mental space
into your your own identity and and I
don't think this is just restricted to
being famous and especially now that the
lines have been blurred so much between
who's famous and who's not famous it
used to be much more clear-cut
but nowadays you can be like you said on
Instagram with a certain number of
followers and you can you know have the
fame is much more of a spectrum now and
and I think it can be really toxic
because what because it's really
addictive I think and and I think
there's a reason for it I don't think
it's like evil or something you know if
you go back I like to think of things in
terms of how it evolved and I like to
think of early humans like you know like
at the beginning of 2001 or something
and if you go back to early early
human-like creatures out on the savanna
trying to survive it probably was an
advantage if everyone in your tribe at
your pack or what everyone call it knew
you that probably meant that you were
more likely to survive and pass on your
genes and so right I think there is
something biological in us that wants
that attention
and and so it's it's not evil if you
feel that urge I think it's pretty
natural but I think that urge now in the
context of modern civilization can be
can be really addictive and sort of
poisonous because what happens is you
start seeing yourself through the eyes
of others more and more of the time and
you start and and I think social media
is really like created a giant leap
forward in this direction and it's the
kind of thing that used to be reserved
for very famous people who are maybe
stalked by paparazzi or whatever but now
everybody's their own paparazzi and and
so I I feel like I see it a lot where
you know the there's there's a good word
to describe it which I learned recently
which is intrinsic versus extrinsic if
you're intrinsically motivated it means
that your motivation for whatever it
might be is kind of coming from within
yourself versus being extrinsic ly
motivated is when your motivation is
coming from without from from other
people from wanting to do things because
of how other people will perceive it and
and I think that's a recipe for
unhappiness usually not absolutely this
isn't a case of black or white and and
there's plenty of virtue to wanting to
do things that will make other people
happy
etc but but when it really gets that
deep inside your head where your whole
identity is sort of becomes a
performance I think that that can be
unhealthy or it can really it can really
do a number on your head and I've seen
it and I've spent my whole life kind of
trying to avoid that sometimes probably
overzealously and and I've
sometimes kind of over protective or
overly allergic to the trappings of fame
etcetera but I'm so I think scared of
falling down that rabbit hole of
becoming overly extrinsically motivated
that that I I really try to stay away
and and and and especially when it comes
to art which you know art and fame have
a are sort of odd bedfellows but because
you know if you want to be a musician
and you want to be an actor a lot of
people I imagine the people you're
describing who really want to be famous
they want to be famous by becoming
actors or becoming musicians or becoming
some other kind of artist and again it's
complicated because on the one hand it
might mean that well that's that that's
means that my my work is resonating with
lots of people and that's not
necessarily bad but if you're only doing
it for that I feel like that's kind of
hollow and I personally feel like I can
hear it in in like or see it in
someone's performance I won't name any
artists in particular but there are
sometimes I'll see a performance in a
movie or like are all hear a song and
I'll be like mmm I just feel I feel like
they're they're performing for their
their their fame not not for them for
themselves for something that's that's
inside of them well you're alluding to
something that has always impressed me
about you and you know what sorry I'm
yeah I want to hear what you but I just
wanna I want to also add I think it's
important because I just sort of pointed
my finger at others I want to say I'm
not entirely innocent of that at all I
and that's probably why it scares me
also is because I've felt it in myself
there's it's very seductive and and and
I'm sure I've been guilty of it in
moments or in in big times you know like
I've been very guilty of it at times I'm
sure but I really try to keep an eye on
it because
because I I've kind of I've seen what it
what it can do to other people and even
to attend myself
right I mean unabated unarrested
uninterrupted if you allow that that I'm
not going to say infection because like
you said there are some very plausible
explanations for why we want or crave
social acceptance or validation but if
you apply jet fuel and steroids to it in
the form of these technological tools
that we now have and now have at our
disposal if all you want is your face to
be recognized by 200,000 more people on
Instagram or a million and a half more
people on Instagram whatever might be it
can be very toxic as you noted and when
I was what I was leading up to is the
observation and this may be incorrect
but at least in a few cases it seems to
be true that you've taken very
deliberate breaks from acting from your
your career in entertainment let's call
it and that goes back to your break for
school yeah where you didn't want to in
an unquestioning way continue on a path
that you were put on at age six right so
it was a deliberate pattern interrupt
and then later you took a bunch of time
off when you had kids and it's I would
imagine that in entertainment perhaps
like in technology and the world of
startups and venture capital and so on
there's a there has to be and I want you
to poke holes in this if it's not true
but there has to be a a degree of fear
of missing out in the industries that
are associated right there there is a
that there must be people who continue
to take whatever jobs they can get
because they have a fear of becoming
irrelevant and that if they step outside
of that slipstream that no one will
remember them X number of years or X
number of months later so they make
compromises
and I'd love to hear you could talk
about any any number of them but how
have you decided what has been the
self-talk and the thinking as you decide
to take breaks yeah
well certainly you're right the the FOMO
is real and it's not just a fear because
I think maybe even more in show business
then maybe any other industry in a
certain way it's it's you know who gets
a job as an actor is very very
emotionally driven you know like studios
have some metrics and stuff that they
look at and they have their math
formulas about you know what actors are
in what movies that make what amounts of
money but compared to say what goes on
in Silicon Valley which is really really
data-driven I'm by the way only having
learned yeah that even means fairly
recently but but it but it's really
emotionally driven who gets hired as an
actor and so it's a lot about you know
quote unquote Heat and if you stop your
yeah your heats gonna die down and uh
it's a real opportunity cost of taking a
break but the two big breaks that you're
talking about one when I quit acting for
a while to go to college and and another
recently I had kids and took a lot of
time off and I'm still kind of taking up
I'm working a lot less right now than I
was before I had kids of course there's
there's a professional opportunity cost
there but it's it's a pretty simple
comparison like what do I care about
more
and I don't want to say that I mean look
talking about parenting is really really
tough because I have found as a parent
because everybody's got their own life
everybody's got a unique scenario and
everybody makes their choices and those
choices are there there's such high
stakes choices that I feel bad even
already just saying what I said because
I don't want to imply that if someone
wasn't able to take as much time off as
I was that they were somehow doing it a
service to their kid said I don't think
that's necessarily true III think that's
too reductive and it's not that simple
everybody's got to do you know what
they've got to do that said I love
having had the chance to work less and
spend more time with my kids and I do
think it's wonderful that there are some
countries in the world that that you
know afford people maternity leave and
even paternity leave that's a lot less
common in in the US and I was just
fortunate enough to have have made money
in my life where I can afford to do it
and have you had people try to talk you
out of taking breaks or has that not
really been something you've you've
encountered you know or you commit to
taking a break and then you get a call
from a manager agent whoever might be in
this say I know you're on break but
we've got this one thing and I think
it's worth considering let's talk about
it that's funny because what that makes
me think of is so I have a longtime
agent named wardens of Allah who he was
actually an agents of mine assistant
when I quit acting and went to school
and he was the one calling me when I was
at school saying like I know you're
going to school but you might want to
consider getting back into acting and
and then once my heat had died all the
way down and in my early 20s and I
wanted to get back into acting and by
the way I had been
known for being on like a TV comedy and
stuff and I didn't want to do that
anymore I wanted to do you know sort of
dramatic and independent films and stuff
and no one really thought that I could
do that and no one really thought that I
was gonna have much more of a career I
thought you know I think pretty much all
of my agents thought well you're that
kid that was on that show and that's
where it ends and that's what happens
with most kids who were on shows for
better or worse what was the show what
was the show and I was on third Rock
from the Sun from age 13 to 19 big show
thank you thank you and when I'm very
proud of and you know remember very
fondly but Warren was the only one
really who who kind of kept calling me
and saying like I I think you could be
good at doing the things that you want
to do and he's still my agent and he was
the one sort of trying to coax me back
into acting when I was taking a break
for college but all these years later
when I had kids he didn't say one thing
like that because he knows me too well
and and we're friends and he wouldn't
you know he had nothing but respect for
me taking the time off that I did and
you know any agents out there listening
take note his proper proper etiquette
yeah really really well done I think and
which isn't to say that he didn't tell
me about the opportunity cost cuz he did
that's his job but when he would tell me
about the opportunity cost he wouldn't
do it in any kind of passive aggressive
way or you know threaten me he would
just be telling me the truth and that's
what's so good about him as an agent he
really just tells me the you know his
perception of the truth of the business
which is not always kind but but is the
most useful information when you were at
that point at 19 let's just say and
there are many non-believers and your
ability to explore these other types of
acting and so on right and I'm looking
at
a piece from The Guardian and feel free
to correct this because there are miss
boats everywhere about everyone ah but
when you were asked what type of acting
you would like to do you wanted to be in
a movie that MyPlate Sundance or
something by Quentin Tarantino and then
it comes that's true yeah and then it
comes to there was a good year or more
if not more of being turned away by
casting directors right and then this
then the quote I want explores this
there were moments days even of
listlessness you know wallowing in self
rejection and loathing and despair
it closes what I also had pretty strong
moments of intense optimism but aside
from Warren's belief in you during that
period right the the one guy who keeps
calling what helps you get through those
periods of rejection and self-doubt are
there any any any tools in the toolkit
or any particular tips you might give to
people who are going through or
certainly at some point will go through
that type of experience of doubting
themselves that's a great question
well the first thing is simply just
having good people around you and I had
that but I think the people who love you
no matter what
and I'm lucky to have had that but
beyond that I goes back to what we were
just talking about a minute ago of being
intrinsically or extrinsic ly motivated
I think it's those are the moments hey
it's easy to be extrinsic ly motivated
when the world's like just giving you a
bunch of thumbs ups right but but it's
in it's in those moments where you you
really just it's it's just you in the
darker times or the years of rejection
right yeah I remember um what if I may
interrupt for a second what what brought
up this intrinsic extrinsic motivation
recently or in the last few years
is that a book that you read that
explored that and was it was it
something else
I believe grit by Angela Duckworth is is
a book that explores this in some
capacity as it relates to parenting so
how to talk to your kids yeah it might
have been that I think I I think I just
heard it from my wife honestly but she
might have gotten if not that book she
might have gotten it from she's read a
fair amount about child development so
and and that is something that we talk
about in terms of parenting wanting the
kid to be intrinsically motivated and
when you over stimulate a kid it can
lead to always chasing that that sort of
outside approval which then leads to and
your adult then you if you can't sort of
find satisfaction in yourself you're
always going to go looking for it
elsewhere and that might take shape and
any number of forms whether it's looking
for you know ending up in a codependent
relationship or an addiction to
something or who knows what or something
much more subtle than that but I yeah I
think I think actually you who thought
of it and I think it probably was in
terms of child development that I that I
learned those words but I did interrupt
you I apologize for interrupting you
than I interrupted now I'm going to
segue out of my interruption so you were
talking about having good people around
you as structure and and anything else
that might come to mind because you're
saying it's it's easy to be
extrinsically oriented when everyone has
given you high fives and like making it
rain with money for great gigs but on
the flip side it's very punishing and
painful to be extrinsically motivated
when you're on the the other side that's
that's just data I remember it was
during this same time that I was trying
to become an actor again and failing mmm
Irish getting rejected a lot this is
right when I started when like really
taking seriously editing and
making my own stuff because I I kind of
came to realize all right I can't I
can't just wait around for someone to
give me a part it's too painful I I have
to be able to get the joy that I get
through creativity on my own can't and I
remember it was around that time I made
a little short film and I submitted it
to the Kotton Film Festival and it was
in French and I like did it anonymously
I didn't go through my agent or anything
I wanted you to see what would happen if
I just didn't like pull any of the
strings or use any of the connections I
had from having worked in show business
before and a short film did not get into
the kind of film festival and I was and
III but I was I was actually surprised
because I thought it was really good and
and and I thought I kind of thought it
would and and a dear friend of mine
who's a filmmaker Rian Johnson his name
who I've been in two of his movies his
first movie prick and then his third
movie looper and he he recently just
made Star Wars the last Jedi he's a
great great filmmaker but also a dear
friend and I remember at that time
having just gotten rejected by the Khan
film festival he recommended that I read
letters to a young poet Rilke Rana Rana
real case sort of a I think a known book
but there's a there's a passage in there
all about solitude and I think it gets a
lot of what we've been talking about in
terms of being an intrinsically
motivated which is so important when
especially I think if you're going to be
an artist although maybe no matter what
you do and it's all about how you have
to just go into yourself
and do your very very best to let
everything outside of that fade away and
and find what's really really going on
in just your own whatever you want to
call it your own psyche your own self
your own whatever and I think in terms
of the kind of dark moments you're
talking about we are facing that kind of
rejection when the world is telling you
you're not going to do what you want to
do we don't want you what really worked
for me
was just kind of ignoring that and and
finding finding motivation of want to
keep making things not for them and
taking on the power into your own hands
to do you to create yeah right start to
finish which I think we're gonna spend a
lot of time what we are going to spend
quite a bit of time on and I'm not sure
if this is a timing connection I'd love
to ask you so if so you mentioned looper
which I'm looking at your filmography it
believed was 2012 yep 2011 it came out
in 2012 right you were busy busy busy
boy in 2012 yeah Dark Knight Rises
Premium rush looper Lincoln lots going
on now I was looking at a GQ piece that
came out August 2012 and I'm I've only
read this name so I'm probably gonna
butcher it is it Zooey Deschanel is that
how you say the name yeah so II perfect
so Zoe said that when the two of you did
500 days of summer together eight years
after first working together you were
lighter and less burdened she said that
you'd changed a lot why do you think she
said that and what contributed to the
change that's funny well
I think she's comparing it to Zoey and I
had done two movies together 500 days of
summer and then I guess eight years
prior we did this movie together called
manic is a little-known tiny budget you
know indie drama which was really really
heavy so that might have contributed
something to it the subject matter being
right yeah we were making a movie about
you know kids in a psychiatric lockdown
facilities yeah I mean I think I I
probably felt like I had something to
prove
in when when she and I first met I was
19 and I was I was up against exactly
that moment that we were just talking
about where I wanted to do a movie that
might play at Sundance right and all my
agents thought that I was that I should
just sign up for another TV comedy for
the next five years and had no belief
that I could do anything other than that
and and the casting directors seemed to
agree with them and yeah I was I was
really worried
I guess and and feeling feeling insecure
about that when did when did hit record
enter the picture and can you tell us
how it came to be exactly the same time
uh-huh all right so yes I thought there
might be a correlation yeah not saying
it's a positive not saying it's causal
but what does hit record and why why did
it why did it manifest well it was in
the midst of those exact times when I
was wanting to get jobs trying to get
jobs failing to get jobs and feeling
like [ __ ] I can't I can't keep waiting
around for someone else to let me be
creative I have
be able to do it on my own and hit
record became this little like turn of
phrase that I would say to myself in
those moments like a little wordplay
about the record button you know
harkening back to the little videos I
would make on family video camera that
had you know a red circle with our EC
over it and when you hit record and you
you start to do it and of course it's
sort of a play on a hit record and and
that was just my little almost kind of
personal mantra or something that I had
to be the one to do it
I wanted to push the button I wasn't
gonna wait to just be an actor and stand
in front of the camera I wanted you know
to hit record and and and the play on
hit record is that the hit record is an
object but to hit record is in action
doing something anyway these are the
kinds of things that I would stay up
late at night musing about what what
would know what what does hit record
become what is yeah it's changed a lot
since then
well I mean I guess I'll just tell the
whole long story right let's do it
we have no rush yeah I'm always I'm
always like telling the short version of
this story now it's to the long version
yeah well so I mentioned earlier that
right around that time I learned to edit
and so I was finally able to kind of
start making things on my own finished
things and this is like 2004 ish so a
little before YouTube and and I wanted
to put the little videos I was starting
to make on the Internet and my brother
helped me set up a little website called
hit record and you know we named it
after this little mantra that I was
saying to myself and it was nothing it
was just a page of HTML where you could
download a couple of quick times of
as I had made and and over the next few
years I would sometimes put a new video
on there things like that and then we
put a message board on there like one of
those old PHP message boards for the
techies out there it looks not too
dissimilar from popular message boards
nowadays like reddit or something but
kind of the the ancestor of that and
anybody could kind of start their own it
was easy if you knew how to do a little
code my brother was a coder so he helped
he put up this message board and we
watched as this little community formed
on a message board around at first
around these little videos that I was
making but what we noticed that was cool
was while some people came and posted on
the message board just to like talk to
me about what I was doing or what I had
made what a lot of people actually
wanted to do was make things together
both with each other and with me and and
we saw that well I say we I mean my
brother and I we're like that's cool
that's that's really new that's unlike
anything you could have done prior to
this new technology and it's different
than than just playing videos on the
internet because that's kind of just
like TV except on a different screen but
if people were actually making things
together through the screen now you're
really kind of like doing something new
and and we leaned into that and and at
this time it was nothing but a hobby we
weren't spending any money we had no
intention of making any money it was
just something we were doing for fun
spent a lot of time on it and had a lot
of fun but it grew and and then I
started thinking and talking with
friends of mine about how this
sort of collaborative process that was
happening within this community on this
message board is would there be a way to
have that operate on a grander scale
could we make things that were sort of
at a quality level could we make like a
short film that would get into Sundance
or could we could we make music that we
could you know releases a record could
we make a book that we published or
could we even maybe one day like use
this methodology to make TV show or
these are the kinds of things we were
wondering and we we said about figuring
out how to do it and we started a
company and you know hired lawyers to
figure out the terms of service because
you know for the intellectual property
of it and everything because we really
wanted to maintain the collaborative
spirit of people not just sort of
submitting a short film and being like
hey I'm now posting my short film to
your website will you try to get it into
Sundance for me but instead having there
be a community of people that are
working together and saying like well I
can do this so I can do this and oh you
wrote something well maybe I'll rewrite
it or maybe I'll draw something based on
what you wrote and then maybe someone
else to be like I like your drawing
maybe I'll animate your drawing and
seeing what can kind of come out of that
and and it started working and and that
was in 2010 we launched it and it's it's
grown a lot since then we did those
things we made short films that got into
Sundance and we published books and we
put out records and we even we made a TV
show that won an Emmy and we've paid
artists a couple million dollars now
over the years and the funny thing
actually I what comes to mind speaking
to you is because you really come from
the world of like you know
entrepreneurship and and business and we
never treated it that way I mean it it
it was it was always more of an art
project even though
it actually it's become profitable over
the last four years it's it's paid for
itself I I bankrolled it at first and
then it started paying for itself but I
remember people or people years ago so
that how are you gonna build it to scale
and I'd be like I don't know what that
means I'm gonna pretend like I don't
care and and it's only now that that
we've sort of accomplished some of the
things that we looked to accomplish and
we're now looking to accomplish even
more ambitious things that I've kind of
come to realize oh you know if we're
gonna do more than just like one TV show
at a time if we're gonna like make lots
of things and involve more and more
people and and really try to set an
example for how the internet could be
something besides just a showcase but
actually a place where people are
productive together we need to make this
thing work as a business in addition to
an art project and it's something we've
that I'm actually excited about recently
that's sort of what I've been focusing
on is figuring out not how to you know I
don't want to like change it really but
just how to figure out how to I guess
arrange it and and and make it make it
work and so that it can really grow and
and make it more accessible to more
people and that's that's what we've been
focused on recently well it seems like
you're well on your way I mean you've
had certainly with the successes on the
platform and the collaborative model
where you're paying out to various
contributors who add their skill sets
and so on to given projects you've
attracted the attention of some very big
brands who have who have come to the
site for help with creative projects and
I want to before I keep traveling on
that thread underscore something that
you said which is this didn't start off
as a business when I started off as an
art project and yeah if even though I
have I can put on the business hat
and I can run different perspective
projects through a business set of
filters my retrospectively and this is
often the only way that you can see
things clearly hindsight being 20/20 but
my best business decisions if someone
were to look at the things that have
turned out financially to deliver the
most value to me personally into the
world quite frankly they did almost all
of them started off with no financial
considerations yeah and I'm not saying
that if you need to make rent payments
that that's the best way to figure out
how to solve that problem it isn't but
if you look at the for instance even my
involvement in tech and startups it
began with me planning out two years of
what would be a real-world MBA because I
wanted to develop certain skill sets and
I was quite frankly just fascinated by
this new world I knew very little about
that a friend of mine was very deeply
involved with or the podcast the podcast
began because I was completely burned
out after completing this book called
the 4-hour chef which was an intense
intense project that should have taken
three years it was crammed into a year
and a half very proud of the product I
don't think we sacrificed there but in
order not to sacrifice there just had to
kill myself effectively for the entire
period of time and the podcast was
something I wanted to experiment with
because I enjoyed being on the
interviewee side of the table so much on
shows like the Joe Rogan experience and
Nerdist and WTF with Marc Maron that I
thought it would be a relaxing but
productive way to decompress I would be
able to focus on getting better at
asking questions while simultaneously
doing something that was completely
different in some respects from writing
a book and no monetization model no
plans to have any type of sponsors
nothing that's how it started and I
think that the reason people ask me all
the time they're like do you still want
to do the podcast are you still having
fun
yeah I am actually still having fun and
I think in part it's because it began
with with that being the sole one of the
sole criterion really for continuing it
was am I actually enjoying this I'm
going to commit to doing six episodes
and if I hate it I'm gonna stop it in
fact if it just bugs me a little bit I'm
gonna stop right and lo and behold I
enjoyed it more than I expected and I
kept doing it so I think that you're in
a great position because this platform
born out of passion of yours and the
others involved in the very early stages
was adopted you've proven out the model
in many respects which by the way a lot
of the best entrepreneurs I know
adopt as their path whether it's Garrett
camp co-founder of uber or others who
help get projects to a very very viable
stage before looking for for instance
any kind of outside funding
[Music]
mcdhh off the preliminaries in a very
organic way that sets you up potentially
now if you want to create something that
is not just self-sustaining but say fast
growing to then bring in partners or
outside funding if if desired if that
makes sense to really multiply how how
large this can become and how quickly it
can become that that's really really
exciting to hear you say that yeah yeah
I know I blue I believe that so at this
point you know what I wanted to just
jump back one second because what you
said reminded me some of something that
I think sort of ties a lot of what we've
been talking about together and that's
when I when I first first first started
acting I was young I was like six right
that hurt very young yeah and my mom
asked me if I wanted to do it I guess
still you know I I had been singing in a
choir and was in some like community
theater and having
grown up in LA some of the kids that
were in my community theater were going
on auditions for commercials and shows
and stuff and she asked if I wanted to
do that
and I said yeah and I was really liked
it but there would be moments sometimes
where I was like I don't feel like going
on an audition today or whatever and she
would always say you really don't have
to do this I want to make sure you never
feel like you have to is it's we're only
doing this because you're enjoying it I
can tell that you really enjoy it but if
at any point you don't want to you
should just stop and she wasn't saying
it and he kind of like manipulative why
she I realized it wasn't a way no she I
think she really wanted to make sure I
had that out and and I eventually did
take the out later in life but it gets
back to what you were saying of doing
something because you really want to do
it and that's that intrinsic motivation
as opposed to extrinsic if it's really
really something you want to do way down
there there's there's kind of no
substitute for that and where with how
are you thinking about the next few
years of your life and hit record and
all these things I mean you have a
family now certainly in a different
place than you were 10 years ago
certainly 15-20 years ago where where is
hit record going and where are you going
do you think in the next in the next few
years yeah I mean look I I love movies
and I hope I get to keep working on them
and buy movies I mean whether it's
movies or TV or whatever it's all kind
of blending together now I hope I get to
keep doing that my whole life but it's
what I would really like to do is try to
find a way to ultimately blend
my conventional career in show business
with what we're doing on hit record and
I think that's still a while away before
these those two sides will really meld
together but but one does kind of feed
the other certainly whenever I have some
success if I'm in a movie that comes out
that does well hitRECord sees a spike
and interest etc and but I I really I
loved the idea of the media being
something different than than what it's
been and I think frankly you know and
maybe ten years ago or so or even a
little more when when kind of what's
been called web 2.0 or was starting up
when YouTube emerged and things like
that
I was really optimistic about that and I
think everyone was this is gonna change
the media there's getting a democratized
media this is gonna you know this is
gonna make it so that the media is no
longer about celebrity and narcissism
and things like that it's going to be
about you know substance and and beauty
and that obviously hasn't quite come to
pass I think I was maybe a little over
optimistic and I I don't think that hit
record is necessarily like the antidote
the be-all and end-all but but it is
it's it's our and I say our like you
know a community now of six hundred
thousand people but it's it's it's our
stab at a different way of doing it
where you don't come on and just say hey
world look at me look at me look at me
look what I'm doing look what I made
it's about like what can we make
together and to me it really feels like
that's that's the promise of the
Internet as a whole is people connecting
to be productive together not just to
kind of like
be endlessly entertained and fed ads and
I that's what you know I hope to try to
foster I find hit record fascinating
also people can check it out hit record
org if that's the best URL to use but in
part because you can peek under the hood
and see how different types of projects
are made and the constituent parts and
the team that is involved and I'm
looking at the site right now you have
the project development slate right if
you have a list of projects that are in
concept development then you have a list
of projects that are in advanced
development then you have a list of
projects and funded projects and people
can get a better understanding and
education about how creative projects
get made from the earliest stages to
final product and it's an opportunity
I'm asked all the time what type of
company should I start from say college
seniors and I taught a lecture I in high
tech entrepreneurship which was a oddly
enough an electrical engineering course
even not oddly because of the title but
because I have no electoral engineering
background whatsoever but I took this
course ele 491 with an incredible
professor named professor Xiao Zi SCH au
and I was invited back to talk to
students and I would I would get asked
very often what type of company should I
start or even worse I hate to say this
but even worse would be what are the
trends right now and what industry
should I go into them like oh god that's
that's setting you up for a lot of pain
if that's the that's the only filter
you're using but it presupposes that
people should out of the gates start
their own company and I'm not saying
that they should or should not but also
what type of movie should I make what
type of album shouldn't put together one
writes and dating happens in movies
absolutely and one of the
recommendations that I often make it's
not always the best fit there are some
people you're just like okay this is the
next Zuckerberg you know what like you
do not need to spend five years at
someone else's company to learn the
ropes but for a lot of folks maybe it is
worthwhile to spend in the case of
startups a year or two years at a
fast-growing start-up so that you see
exactly how this puzzle looks when it is
put together in the early stages and to
really build an education and skill sets
and relationships that will then help
you when you decide to start your own
thing and I think the hit record is also
an opportunity to do that collaborative
it's like alright you think you might
want to launch a career as a musician
you think you might want to launch
career as a filmmaker well why not kick
the tires by contributing on a product
or a project rather in one of those
categories before you decide to bet the
farm or jump headfirst into one of these
things so I think that it's really a
fascinating opportunity to educate
yourself and develop skills and
relationships simultaneously even if you
are not aiming to start your own project
if that makes sense I mean that's it's
funny you say that because actually
that's that's one of the things we tell
people who just join is don't start out
by starting your own thing find someone
else's thing that you like and help them
and contribute because there's lots of
people on there talented people who've
got their own projects going and they
need contributions whether it's music or
a writing project or a film project or
you know a design project there's you
know we kind of do all kinds of media
but they need those contributions to
come in and that's the best way to start
getting involved if you if you show up
on hit record and immediately say I'm
starting my own project it's sort of
like walking into you know a production
company as you know the first day on the
job entry-level and saying like okay
everybody follow me I'm going to lead a
you know this whole company in a project
now might work sometimes but but more
often it's it's better to like you say
work on other people's stuff first get
you know get your feet wet
and and learn how it goes because the
way things get made on hit record is
really different than the way things get
made in anywhere else in the world sort
of because it's this open collaborative
process it's very different than I mean
there are similarities and differences
to say a conventional movie set but on a
conventional movie set not anyone can
just stroll on and offer their ideas
throw in their two cents or you know
write a scene those doors aren't open
whereas on hit record anybody can and
and you know then there's a whole
process of finding okay well if anybody
can come in and try to make stuff you
need people that are going through all
the contributions and finding finding
the ones that are the most applicable
that can they can be useful in the final
production and there's it's a it's sort
of its own beast and and one I've come
to really love but it takes some getting
used to for sure and so I I totally
agree get started by finding someone on
there who you admire you think is is
good at what they do and see what
they're up to and see if you can help
them and this applies to so many
different domains also it makes me think
of Y Combinator and for people who don't
know what Y Combinator is you can think
of it as the Harvard meets Navy SEALs of
startup incubators that's that's a one
way to think about it the acceptance
rate is exceptionally exceptionally low
and they start off with very short
actually should say they filter
applications first then the next round
as at least last I checked this is
constantly evolving in Y Combinator's
become incredibly incredibly powerful
also a lot of great essays by one of the
co-founders Paul Graham programs that's
great right yeah if people want to look
up one of my favorites I think it's
managers schedule versus makers schedule
also very helpful for creatives but one
of the questions and I'll paraphrase but
a a paraphrase version of one of the
questions that they very commonly ask or
at least did for a long period
time was tell us about something you've
made or something that you've you've
made recently and that doesn't have to
be from blank slate and just as you
noted in your undergraduate experience
some of the classes might have been
super compelling but a lot of them were
very abstract and based on rote
memorization and not putting the rubber
to the road the in my experience if you
want to learn how to do X go do X and
particularly if there's a way to do it
with minimal risk where you have the
opportunity to observe other people who
are attempting the same thing and for
some that might take the form of say
going to RISD in learning design and
having active critiques and I'm actually
sitting on something called crit buns
which is literally an ass cheek
supporter that was the first real
product made by Joe Gebbia co-founder of
Airbnb need some support yeah [ __ ] buns
there you go so Joe please give me my
customary five percent but where I'm
going with that is that hit record and
other environments that allow this type
of open collaboration for instance I'm
an advisor to a company called automatic
ma TT automatic for those who are
wondering how that was named well the
founders name is Matt Mullenweg
there you go insider automatic is his
first name in the company name but he
was one of the if not considered the
lead developer on WordPress and you can
see this type of beautiful collaboration
and you also see look in any large
community you're also going to have some
strife and the occasional village idiot
that's gonna happen but this this
incredible dynamic of organic creation
that comes out of an open source project
like that I think you can also see on
hit record but in a very in some cases a
very visual medium so in any case that's
just my my way and I am I don't have any
secret equity stake in the record I just
think it's I think it's a I think it's a
very very
exciting environment and sandbox in
which creatives can experiment so I
that's Glee to say man thank you yeah so
- I mean you're it's you said 600,000 or
so people let me know when you when you
hit a million and I'll take a short
video of me taking a tequila shot and
shoot it back over to you and I want to
be respectful of your time you have
you've so many different things that you
can spend your time on so I really
appreciate you taking time to have this
conversation
first of all comment my pleasure
sincerely and do you have any parting
words requests of the audience anything
that you'd like to convey or suggest or
ask before we before we wrap up you know
the last thing that I might say and it
it does connect to a lot of the other
things we were saying is just then we
were when you were talking about how if
you want to do X go and do X if you want
to learn to do something if you're
considering a career for example as a
musician or as a writer or an animator
maybe hit record might be a cool step I
would just talk about the other side of
the coin which is without any goal at
all if it just feels good to you maybe
you don't want to be a professional
artist of any kind but I think there's
there's a lot of people out there who
have that urge to make stuff that don't
necessarily want to you know dedicate
their entire life to it
I think that's equally important that's
sort of a part of creative culture that
in a certain way I feel like where we
lose track of sometimes in in this world
where you know Silicon Valley is is so
excited to say to everybody we're
democratizing media and entertainment
and now anybody can be a superstar like
that's cool but you know in in in older
times
if you wanted to hear music well there
wasn't a radio and there wasn't a
gramophone if you wanted to hear music
it was going be because like your uncle
happened to you know play an instrument
or something and you would hear music
because not not because you were
listening to professionals play it or a
recording of a professional playing it
you would hear your clothes people
around you friends family that's the you
know original meaning of folk music and
and in fact it's also the original
meaning of pop music popular music
popular Maine people its people and and
I think that's the same same goes for
storytelling
or for art of any kind really there's
there's something really beautiful about
people who aren't necessarily trying to
be the next superstar but who have that
that creativity in them and want to want
to do stuff with it I think that's also
really important to let out of you and
you don't have to measure it up against
well but if I put my song on the
Internet or my story is it going to get
enough likes or is my or they didn't
think that I saw who [ __ ] care that's
really not that's not what's gonna
ultimately make you happy that ties back
to the fame question like it's what's
gonna make you happy is if you have that
urge to do it and that's that's kind of
where hit record came from for me and
that that's what I hope that it can
continue to be for most the people that
come aren't necessarily trying to be
pros there are some that are and and
oftentimes those the folks that end up
leading but but most people are just
having a good time making stuff together
and and that I never want hit record to
lose that
so definitely what it's worth I think is
worth a lot and I'm trying to pay more
and more attention to what I would do if
I couldn't tell anyone or show anyone
I'm one of those things or maybe it's
limited to two or three friends who come
over on Friday nights to have a glass of
scotch and just say hey what the [ __ ]
have you been up to
alright what do I show them right and
that's it that's the limit of the
audience I'm not doing market testing
and that can lead some to some really
beautiful places so I'm spending more
time thinking about that myself so I
appreciate the reminder where where can
people say hello if they want to try to
say hello on the interwebs on if you're
on the socials if there is anything that
you'd like to put out there to the world
if people would like to wave a hand or
if you can leave it a hit record or go
there are there any other any other
places that you would like to to mention
before we put a put a pin in it yeah if
you want to make stuff together hit
records that that's kind of what it's
for
and and I am on on Twitter and Facebook
and Instagram so you can check those out
too all right I will link to the real
accounts in the show notes just so you
don't have just a fan account I don't
want to have people go through 17 of
those so for people listening as you
know if you're a long-term listener but
if you're not let me tell you a little
bit about how the show works we will
have links to everything including
hitRECord org including the books that
were mentioned letters to a young poet
very powerful book that I recommend to
everyone as a side note save the cat and
I also actually think is is one of the
despite some of the cynicism and
sterility of a few aspects of it is get
a very helpful book as a starting point
when thinking of screenwriting and also
calls me on my own [ __ ] meaning I've
been talking about and thinking about
screenwriting for so long to the extent
that I have fans who are hassling me
about it and thank you for hassling me
about it everybody out there so taking a
page from this conversation on if you
want to learn it just do it I think I
have to stop reading books I have to
stop asking people for advice and just
actually sit down
and stare at that intimidating blank
page right if I had a few shorts first
that's exact that would be my advice I'm
gonna get on it so a few shorts and Joe
thank you so much again for taking
thumbs there's a lot of thank you to em
and to everybody listening until next
time thank you for listening
seriously hey guys this is Tim again
just a few more things before you take
off number one this is five bullet
Friday do you want to get a short email
from me and would you enjoy getting a
short email from me every Friday and
that provides a little morsel of fun
before the weekend and five bullet
Friday is a very short email where I
share the coolest things I've found or
that I've been pondering over the week
that could include favorite new albums
that I've discovered it could include
gizmos and gadgets and all sorts of
weird [ __ ] that I've somehow dug up in
the the world of the esoteric as I do
it could include favorite articles that
I have read and that I've shared with my
close friends for instance and it's very
short it's just a little tiny bite of
goodness before you head off for the
weekend so if you want to receive that
check it out just go to 4-hour workweek
dot-com that's 4-hour workweek comm all
spelled out and just drop in with your
email and you'll get the very next one
and if you sign up I hope you enjoy it
this episode is brought to you by
wordpress.com
I love WordPress I have used it for so
many years it's my go-to platform for
blogging and creating websites I use
wordpress.com for everything every day
my site Tim that blog is built on it the
websites for my books including tools of
titans tribe of mentors all and
wordpress.com and the founder matt
mullenweg
when they're close friends has appeared
on this show many times
just search Matt Mullenweg tequila
Ferriss or quite an exciting time
whether you're looking to create a
personal blog a business site or both
you can make a really big impact right
out of the box when you build on
WordPress talk
and you'll be in good company it's used
by the New Yorker jay-z Beyonce at 5:38
TechCrunch Ted CNN from time just to
name a handful and one of my friends at
Google children nameless has told his
pet wordpress.com
offers the quote best out of the box SEO
imaginable and put it's one of the many
reasons that nearly 30 percent of the
Internet is run on WordPress you do not
need experience or to hire something
that's perhaps the best part
wordpress.com guide you through the
entire experience they have hundreds of
designs and templates that you can use
and it's easy to get started there's no
need to worry about security upgrades
posting any of that they offer 24/7
support and they're very very responsive
a few questions they go right back to
you and this allows you to create the
highest quality of the least amount of
headache and friction so if you're
building a website period when my
friends come to me and ask what I use
what I recommend they use the answer is
wordpress.com so check it out if you
want to get started today learn more
with a 15% discount off any new plan go
to wordpress.com forward slash to Tim
create your website and find the plan is
right for you it's a little more take a
look
wordpress.com 4/10 at 15% off a brand
new what check it out
this episode is brought to you by four
sig Matic if you're a longtime listener
of the show or brand new to the podcast
my favorite Finnish entrepreneurs who
founded this company of course I don't
know that many Finnish entrepreneurs but
they may be my favorites have something
new that I've been loving and some of
you are familiar with for somatic I've
used their products for years now
they're in juice to me by an acrobat of
all folks and they tend to mix different
types of medicinal mushrooms into their
products I have recently started using
their matcha which is a green tea which
is designed as a coffee alternative and
if you're trying to cut back on caffeine
as I am these days the matcha is a great
option and one that I originally learned
to love in Japan has a very smooth
texture to it they're matcha blend in
particular includes the amino acid adult
theanine which helps to provide a let's
call it balance boost of energy without
jitters it also includes the adaptogen
astrologists I'm pronouncing that
correctly which may help with overall
stress tolerance and for those of you
who are wondering know the products
don't taste like mushrooms if they say
mushroom coffee for instance another
product that I use doesn't taste like
mushrooms it tastes like coffee but you
get the nutritional benefits of some of
these special ingredients so the
products don't taste like mushrooms and
are enjoyable I offer them to my
houseguests and use them myself and I
don't particularly want to drink
anything that tastes like mushrooms
so moving on the folks at Forsyth matic
have designed a few special deals for
you guys my listeners which include many
of my favorite products of theirs so
check it out visit for sig Matic fo you
are SI g ma TI c comp org slash Tim Tim
its TI m TI m no space to see these
special deals which are not offered
anywhere else remember to use the code
Tim Tim I don't know why they just Tim
Tim but there we go
remember to use the code Tim Tim a check
out to receive your special discount
again that's for sig Matic dot-com
forward slash Tim Tim and enter the
promo code 10
check it out
you
you